thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slam net from Norway are
establishing a Masjid a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even
how are you guys doing I'm here in Oslo
in Norway in a tour that we're doing
here in Scandinavia to see whether the
sentiments that we're seeing with the
islamophobic elements the anti-islamic
elements burning the Quran and so on
which has been covered all over
international news is wide or are widely
shared among the public the populace
here in for example Scandinavian regions
so we're going to be asking people what
they think about that particular action
whether they support it so we can see
whether or not this is a representation
of the main uh kind of opinion here in
Scandinavia
all right can I ask you a question we're
just doing an experiment here in Oslo
yes we were just asking people members
of the public I'm not sure if you've
seen on the news in Scandinavia and
Sweden and other parts of the world
there's a fad here in Scandinavia now
with some individuals coming and burning
the holy books the Muslims like the
Quran and so on
what do you think of the idea of burning
a holy book
um without having given it much thought
I don't think you should burn any books
spread it's bad okay yeah how about
yourself I don't know if it's maybe bad
I think it's unnecessary to if it's not
your religion then why would you do
something
hateful towards others it's unnecessary
why would you burn a book if you don't
agree with religion it's
just let people believe
well I mean people have their own
freedom for their own religion and I
think they should have that in peace
it's not anyone's business what other
people believe so if someone if someone
wants to go against what I believe I
would feel
that was that's not good so yeah my I I
don't think people should judge each
other based on religion color anything
so I yeah I think we should just coexist
in peace people are not interested in
this kind of thing and they're not
interested in trying to you know hurt
Muslim feelings as she said it well you
know what's the point of doing something
which is going to enrage the community
of of people in the country what's the
point of it it doesn't make any sense at
all and so once again sometimes we can
get the wrong impression that the ideas
of a few people say in Scandinavia or so
on or any other part of the world is
representative of the bulk of people
which isn't here we're seeing first hand
well in order for this kind of project
to continue for us to continue showing
showcasing this to to outreaching to
people to speaking to somebody slams
having these genuine and authentic
conversations
then yes we need to support the Dao
project here in Norway and in the rest
of Scandinavia I'm giving you an
opportunity here and myself to click the
link below where you can actually
monetarily help out to the cause and I
would say do not miss on this
opportunity it's a very important one
some people make the argument though for
example they all say this is actually an
expression of freedom of speech and
expression do you think this is an
appropriate way of manifesting freedom
of spiritual expression no in Norway we
have a saying that if you don't have
anything nice to say then you shouldn't
say it out loud I think that yes you
should have the freedom of speech but if
it's hurtful to other people what's the
point of of saying it you know yes I
mean from their perspective the argument
they would say is that well the reason
why they're doing it is because they
think there's a Muslim a a credible
Muslim threat in Norway that needs to be
resisted and challenged and so we have
to burn their holy books because that's
where they get their ideas they would
say of all these kind of um terroristic
ideas and so on do you think this is a
legitimate argument
no no I will not disappointed us no yes
I don't really see it as a threat so
yeah
yes and do you think that your opinion
is representative of the majority of
Norwegians or do you think that
Norwegians will think actually we should
burn the book because we should you know
this is something we should Challenge
and we should take advantage of our
freedom expression what kind of opinion
do you think majority of your friends
and family would have they will say the
same as me yes yeah so so it's not
representative these people who are
doing this of the majority of people
that you know no no
I think those are the same opinion as me
yes like
if you if you're not engaged in your
religion just just don't care about it
just don't do nothing why would you
actually use your own time and resources
to first get the book and then burn it
for no real benefit
so there you have it folks we've seen
without a shadow of it the majority of
people that we've seen in fact all of
them that we've discussed with have said
that they don't think this is a
necessary thing they don't think is a
good thing in fact the statistics that
be done in the matter and the people who
actually support this is a very very you
know Fringe minority you could say
support the action that not only they
should be given the right to burn the
book but it is an appropriate action in
the first place both steps are required
in order for the action to be supported
and those who actually support this
action in that manner or maybe a fringe
minority of the people in this country
with that being said guys I think now
it's time to realize that when you
consider that the biggest Masjid in
Tower Center the biggest Center for
Muslim if you like education in the
entire region of Scandinavia is being
constructed and I've seen the extensions
themselves they are putting the money in
the right place and physical and
tangible resources and that these kinds
of programs can be done Outreach
programs can be done training programs
can be done the mosque is there for the
Muslim Community there's programs for
the young people all of that stuff is
there now I think it's high time we
really lies that we need to contribute
to this to for our survival quite
frankly in this in these countries in
the West for our continued existence
that we can normalize Islam and Muslim
uh you know being in in these kinds of
places and you must click and don't be
afraid that if you give to the sake of
Allah you will be uh depreciated
that
money does not depreciate with giving
charity so now it's time to click on the
link below and go ahead and donate to
this course and you'll see the fruits in
our generation inshallah and the
generations
brothers and sisters let me introduce
you to Norway this is a European country
where the vast majority of people have
become irreligious there are 200 000
Muslims of a population of about 5
million and most of these 200 000
Muslims have no idea how to explain
Islam to their non-muslim friends and
neighbors what that means to change
Allah his Messenger to call people to
Eternal success and that is why Muslims
in Norway are now establishing a Masjid
and Tower Center to enhance the
Norwegian dower but they cannot do this
alone we need to support them if you
donate to the schools you will insha
Allah reap the rewards thousands of
Muslims coming back to Islam and many of
those will become Dwight and invite to
Islam you will share in the reward for
all those shihadas and Good Deeds to
come in so click the link and donate now
and share the video for extraord